welcome to build with Google Cloud where
we create reference architectures we've
all used some sort of social media
application for humans but how cool
would it be to create a social media
application for pets in this episode
I've invited Christopher who built a pet
social media on Google Cloud hi
Christopher hi rianca I'm sorry excited
to share the process of building and
deploying the application
great so before we dive into how to
actually build this pet social media
application why would actually someone
want to even build an application like
this building a social media aside can
be beneficial in many cases maybe you
are a business wanting to create a
platform to manage your communities
maybe you like me are learning to build
impressive projects with Google Cloud we
can showcase your ability to build an
end-to-end scalable application I
absolutely agree with all both of those
use cases if you are building your Cloud
portfolio and are ready to show off some
of your practical experience this is a
great fun project to take on and put on
your resume okay so the first things
first in order to get started with this
application what are some of the
challenges that we need to think about
great question building and scaring a
social media website can be a tedious
task for developer as a number of user
grow you will have to worry about
managing different servers
authentication handling heavy traffic
Network and database don't worry that's
where Google Cloud Server is coming to
help you worry less about scaling so you
can focus on more on coding great so I'm
definitely ready to get started in
seeing the process of picking the
products so should we go yes great
[Music]
here are some of the core features that
we want to implement in this social
media application log in or create a new
account
view news feeds of recommended posts
follow other users make a new post or
edit delete old ones with that in mind
where do we start okay let's say our
size past social media.com a social
media website makeup bets and our user
are assessing by typing the social
media.com in the browser we will use
cloud DNS short for domain name system
to receive the request from the user
device and respond back with an IP
address to establish a connection to our
server in this case say you already have
your front end ready on the localhost
however to be able to have designed
online you definitely need a server
minimal functionalities and user may
work with the single server however when
you have more user you may need to scale
it up
luckily serverless Cloud run can handle
scaling ultimately based on the number
of requests or user so we're choosing
Cloud run here because it is a
serverless container platform that
scales automatically and you can easily
and automatically deploy to Cloud run
every time you push your commit to
GitHub or a code version control of your
choice with Cloud build Cloud build
really is a Google Cloud serverless CI
CD platform what happens if our pet
social media goes viral and all of a
sudden a large number of pets across the
globe want to be part of it Christopher
when our size grows globally you may
want to deploy more than one server from
regions closer to the user providing
faster connection and better user
experience
to handle the traffic we use cloud Lloyd
balancer if it uses send a request from
Asia for example the cloud load balancer
will help send that request to a server
in azure to avoid Interruption you can
also use cloud word balancer to handle
traffic to different servers if one
research limit
okay great now we need our users to have
a login how do we set them up for login
next you may want to handle login create
new user with high security level
less time coding and more
functionalities such as signing in with
Google or GitHub this step can be done
with identity platform a customer
identity and assess management that help
organization add identity and assess
management functionalities to the
application protect user account and
scale with confidence on Google clouds
when you first create your account you
may want to provide user data such as
name type of pass location
bio acceptor in this example name type
location bio will be treated at
relational database
for relational database this data can be
stored locally in systems such as MySQL
or busgrade SQL with Google Cloud you
can replace MySQL or postcard SQL with
Cloud SQL or migrate your assistant
database to cloud with database
migration
so the database migration service lets
you transfer your data already into a
cloud SQL and Cloud SQL the choice of
cloud SQL here is really because it is a
managed version of my SQL so you really
don't have to like worry about scaling
and replication and Google Cloud does
that for you
so now for the actual post what are the
things that we need to consider
I may have images of the pet made the
pet want to say something about that
image like tuning at the beach how do we
handle that in the application will you
make a pause there's two main bases at
GPO you may consider caption and the
media while the caption is in relational
database post media such as images and
videos however I traded at
non-relational data if you store the
file locally and the cache connection to
the side will be slow when you have high
traffic and many files uploaded to
handle this we can use cloud storage to
store post images or videos now we
talked about the global users and you
know this application is pretty popular
amongst the global Peg community and we
know that Network and bandwidth is
different in different parts of the
world so how do we handle those
challenges many of you may have high
quality images or videos taken from
smartphone or digital camera big size
images or videos may take longer to be
uploaded to handle this we can use cloud
function a scalable base as you go
function as a server product to help you
build and connect event driven services
with simple and single purpose code
Cloud function can help reduce the file
size before uploading to cloud storage
making it more suitable for viewing
purposes for the caption you can store
the caption in Cloud SQL you can also
utilize caption with machine learning in
pre-chain solution some of my favorites
are using the translation API to
translate the caption if it's in another
language
or you can use recommendation AI to
suggest who to follow you can always
train your own machine learning model
with vertec AIS or Auto ml okay now
let's say I am the pet symbol and I have
an account I hop onto the application
what is my experience like
when you are authenticated the first
thing you want to see is the new fit
oppose made by user you follow or
suggested post make based on your
interest
in addition you may want to see some
initial content from the people you
follow especially those with many lies
or common this can be easily achieved by
Cloud CDN or content delivery Network to
store the cash of those High interactive
Post finally for the following function
you can give pops up to subscribe and
send notification every time you get a
new follower similarly you can use pops
up to send you notification someone
comment on your post
so now that we know how and what we need
to put
there let's put together what we have
built so far yes let me show you first
you need a front end we can handle basic
function on the localhost and store
images in the local directory
then Cloud DNS server will handle
requests from your device when you type
the size to the browser
next you will need to deploy your web
app on cloud run or app engine server
which can help you scale your app
ultimately based on requests you can
make use of cloud Bill to ultimately
deploy your web app through your repo
at this stage depend on the scale of
your site you may need more than one
server and Cloud load balancers to
handle traffic between different server
then Cloud identity platform can help
you authentication processes such as
signing in or signing up
after you or authenticated you may want
to see the newsfeed with a cloud CDN
will store the top interactive posts
from the user you follow at Cash
when you make a post Cloud SQL will help
you store information such as caption
post location
Etc why clustered help you store media
files such as images or videos at this
step you can use cloud function to
reduce the file size to make them more
accessible
after that whenever you get a comment on
your post or someone follow you pops up
will help you subscribe the message and
handle sending notification
finally there's many use case for
machine learning you can either use no
on low code solution with pre-kane apis
such as translation API to translate the
post caption if the caption is in
another language or if you prefer to
write your own machine in the model you
can consider to train your model with
vertex AI wow that was a lot and very
interesting if you stuck around this far
then congratulations you just learned
how to build a social media application
with Google Cloud check out the link in
the description to view architecture of
this project
there is definitely a lot more to
explore but I am confident that this
will get you started if you like this
video I hope you smash that like And
subscribe button to receive more useful
content and tutorials on building with
Google Cloud